[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this
is a show for you if you're bored of
watching people actually do you know
what um we've got a very special guest
for you this week guys
quite simply we've realized we haven't
pissed off enough people so we've
invited a very special guest on
who will wind up a few more yes you will
our guest this week is a controversial
youtube comedian
count dankula welcome to trigonometry
how you doing
[Music]
it's good to have you man listen for
anyone who doesn't know you let's just
quickly get the whole thing out of the
way
you're known for the nazi pug video
which you made for youtube which went
viral you had a core case that resulted
from that tell us very quickly about
that for anyone who doesn't know
i made a joke and get arrested
essentially my
girlfriend was constantly going on about
how cute and adorable her pug was she
wouldn't shut up about it
i thought it would be funny to teach the
dog to do horrific things like nazi
salute and react to the phrase
gas the jews and i made a video of it
it went online it went viral i got
arrested
i went through a two-year trial which
lasted
twice as long as the nuremberg trials
and
ultimately i was found guilty and they
find 800 pounds
which i've refused to pay and so now it
was just a case of waiting for the cops
to come and get me
obviously this wasn't in the uk you were
living in north korea at the time no no
that was this was in
the united people's republic of scotland
[Laughter]
oh yeah that's that's what all went down
yeah right
and where are you with it now because
you've had a bunch of appeals and and
stuff like that
um i ended up i went through tried to go
through the actual
regular appeal process and the way it
works is there's like a sift
process it's basically to stop people
from wasting the appeals court's time
for example a man could walk into the
police station with his decapitated
wife's head in his hand
with a usb stick containing the video of
him doing it
and then he would go i want to appeal
it was a system set up to prevent people
like that from wasting their appeal
court's time
and what happens is at the first stage
one judge reviews it
and it was basically a huge fuse fused
before wheels
thing where he basically told me i was
lucky i didn't go to jail
and he even threatened my lawyer with
contempt of court for
doing his job and they ended up the
second time
after that we appealed again the second
ser got rejected we then did something
called nobody efficient
which is where you appeal to the highest
judge in the land going
can you please hear me out because i'm
getting [ __ ] up here
we then went in front of the highest
judge in the land who went no
and then just sent us on our way so that
was a very expensive no
and now the only thing we've really got
left is the scottish criminal case
review commission which can take
months and i could get packed up at any
time and
do my time in jail before they even
process a submission so
yeah [ __ ] it's pretty [ __ ] yeah so
how long could you do in jail
essentially and and
more importantly this is the thing that
blew my mind what did you get charged
with
it was section section 127 the
communications act of 2003
uh posting a offensive message or
offensive content on a
social media platform so it was i was
literally convicted over causing
gross offense something which is uh
completely
subjective and also you know they kind
of
replaced my intent and removed the
context of what i did
in order to secure that conviction
because here's the thing that worries me
it's like who gets to judge what is
offensive like i'm a west ham fan i find
their back four
at times grossly offensive you know
infuriating and
but who's to who makes that judgment the
scottish courts that's what the
prosecution of the crown said
he says that people don't get to decide
what they find offensive
the court gets to decide what isn't as
an offensive i am not joking
he literally said that do they not also
say that context
and intent are irrelevant yeah he said
that
they were allowed to woefully ignore
certain contextual parts of the evidence
they were said that they were allowed to
do that so basically we are allowed to
disregard context
so basically they said that there's
parts of the evidence that we are
allowed to completely dismiss
that's what he said and it's just like
this
he's a massive authoritarian like the
prosecutor i don't know if it's a case
of he actually believes those things or
he just really really wanted a win
yeah because he was going he was going
ham there was even a few
things that he said well the judge
raised a bit of an eyebrow like
come on man that's a little bit extreme
but you know he won in the end
i mean that's incredible to say that
context is not
important so that basically dismisses
irony
basically the entire cast of django is
looking at life
context doesn't matter they're looking
at some serious hard labor
it's interesting with the implications
because i haven't mentioned we're here
at the backyard comedy club and marcus
is about to do a set here tonight
and by the time this video goes out he
will already have done a set um so for
comedy
and for any comedy whether that's online
whether that's comedians going on stage
like us stand-up comedians
what are the implications of this
because this is scary stuff man
well it's a case of a president has now
been said well you know context doesn't
matter your intent doesn't matter even
if there's
evidence supporting what your intent was
that can all be ignored and disregarded
courts can essentially guess the
thoughts which are in your head
when you you know said the joke and they
can decide for themselves the reason why
you said it if even if you're on stage
going
i'm doing a comedy gig i'm saying these
things to be funny
the judge can go no you said it because
you were being racist that's
that's literally where we're at right
now and people are saying oh no it's not
going to happen it's not going to happen
but we've already had
arrests happen we've had the chelsea
russell we've had but one guy who got
the calicity's door because he
liked a tweet containing a limerick
about trans people the police actually
contacted him to say
we are we just wanted to call you to
check your thinking
and not mind and see how we were
commenting on this earlier but it's like
whenever people say
thought police people used to go home
and roll their eyes people aren't
rolling their eyes so much anymore
especially when you get the police
calling you to say that they're there to
literally check your thinking like
that's
terrifying that's that's the road that
we're going down and i've been trying to
raise more awareness about this for the
last two years i mean
there'll be some people who say right
okay why don't you just pay the 800 quid
get it over it get it done 800 quid
isn't it a big deal
i'm scottish
pay the government money sorry i'm not
the man i'll pay 100 quid to park a car
[Laughter]
join us for episode 2 where marcus
glasses me in a pub
so anyway i've taken that brings us all
to the tories
no but it is as a case of i shouldn't be
facing any punishment at all so
i'm just going to be a salty stick in
the mud i'm going to go [ __ ] your fine
i'm not paying you're [ __ ] fine
all i did was hurt people's feelings
like why i mean think of everything i've
been through like so far when i'm losing
all my jobs i'm getting depressed
constantly harassing me and my family
and it's like
you know sure you'd think that would be
enough but they're like no we want this
800 pounds and it's the thing they want
and they're not [ __ ] getting that i'm
not paying the money
well the thing is as well we had a chat
about this one for your documentary that
the bbc are doing about you right
what you're saying is you haven't paid
the fine and they should have come and
take you
taken you off to jail already but they
haven't well this was the thing is i
think the
the final date was the 26th of october
and it was a case of
you know after that date passed i went
cool here we are it's go time
let's go 10 minute any second now i'm
going to get that knock at the door
but like two weeks passed and i was like
was
what what's going on where the hell are
they and i ended up going christmas is
coming i'm getting
married next year let's just rip this
off like a plaster and get it over and
done with
so i called the cops on myself and just
basically went
hello you know i'd like to report a nazi
i'd like to report me
you know you've got my address you've
got this you've got that and i was like
when are you coming to get me and they
said we're not going to come and get you
until your name flags up on the computer
so literally i get saved by
bureaucracies oh man but i was
i was even like but i'm here on the
phone with you now
telling you where i am you know what man
they wouldn't come and get me so
i'm probably going to get picked up at
the most an opportune time
probably you know as i'm getting shipped
through my house to the wedding venue
yeah something like that probably then
wouldn't it surprise you saved by the
police
sitting in the back of the car
no worries you really helped me out yeah
well listen man you wanted to piss off
your girlfriend it looks like that's
really going to happen now right
it works every time there's an argument
she brings it up you know when your
relationships when she's got that one
thing you did
years ago that she always brings up
that's that's mine
that's the one that's you always told
that dog to do it
none of this would have happened but you
know what's interesting is
let's explore the counter argument
because there are some people who say
what you do was normalize hate speech
you know it's anti-semitic where do you
stand on that
normalizing hate speech we've always
hate speech more prevalent
you know if you look at the last century
people were hella racist
people were extremely racist so how can
hate crime and all that be on the rise
like yeah it's getting reported no more
because it's now catalogued as a lot as
a crime we now
have metrics by which to measure it but
in the past we didn't but society was
hella racist
back then racism is on the decrease so
everyone's saying like you've normalized
what i've
normalized something that is in fact
fading away i guess what francis is
saying is
by showing those images where if someone
is stupid enough to take what you did
literally
right right right let's just move that
because they would have to be really
stupid yeah that would be a new level of
stupid yeah
right exactly although to be fair there
probably is
probably the dog made me do it it's your
honor
that dog has a point there is a stat
from america that seven percent of
americans think that chocolate milk
comes from brown cows right so so there
are people that are stupid enough so
let's just play the argument the counter
argument right let's say that they're
people who are stupid enough and maybe
racist enough to take that literally
and they're going to go oh it's
acceptable now to do nazi themed
dog training videos you know and they're
going to then be emboldened this is the
tell you what it might
[Laughter]
but this argument is so [ __ ] stupid i
can't even get it out
i understand what you're trying to say
people see people see the video and then
they get inspired like oh you know
doing that is okay well it would depend
on the context in which they're doing it
like see for example if they did it with
like a kitten
or something like that like if it's a
cute thing would it sort of take if
someone did it with a pig that'd be kind
of funny
yeah as well like that'll be quite good
then yeah and that'd be okay
see if a guy just dresses up as a nazi
and starts hanging around the synagogue
shooting it that's when i'd be like whoa
no no that's that's not you know that's
not funny if you're shooting
threats jews well dressed as a nazi like
it's different but like the context is
the dog the animal and as far as a i've
had a few people say your video could
actually directly inspire
violence from people if anyone watches
my video
and that inspires them to go out and
commit violence
then anything [ __ ] would have an
episode of the [ __ ] peppa pig
man it's like if that video caused that
person to go out and commit an act of
violence then
the bar was very very low like that
person was going to come out of violent
act sooner or later
i don't see you know that that problems
with them you know if people
look at a piece of entertainment and
they interpret it into you know
real world horrific acts you know it's
the same as making the argument
video games cause violence heavy metal
causes devil worship
uh jazz music causes white women to
dance with black men
that was one in the 40s by the way that
was a thing they actually tried to push
but like
it's just making those same arguments
but it's a casey even though
media is done with a certain intent to
be entertainment to be
funny people try and take it and
transfer it into the real life not
realizing no it's just
entertainment that's all that says and
see if anyone transforms
entertainment not seeing it for what it
is and transforms it into real world
horrific actions then they deserve to be
in a jail cell and society's better off
without them to be honest
because there's people like that that
are ruining it for everybody else
because
basically the only way to get around
that stuff is just to make everything
walking on eggshells you know don't say
or do certain things in case some
maniac decides to do something mental
with the information you received i mean
do you think the author of catch 22
knew that that guy was going to pop off
john lennon
that was a catch on the right that was
catch me in the right yeah i keep
getting those mixed up yeah it was
catching in the right like he he didn't
know that he wasn't trying to inspire
that he was
i wasn't trying to inspire that way what
i did
but that's the argument people try and
make and the only way to
you know comply with their demands is to
literally
censor the vast majority of media and
make it so mild to us which would just
overall restrict
expression and where do you stand on
this issue of freedom of speech do you
think there is a problem with freedom of
speech in this country or do you
yeah i believe there are certain things
that uh
government-wise there's certain things
that you see if it's someone directly
inciting violence then
i do have an understanding right
personally i'm an absolutist but i'm
prepared to make some concessions in
certain areas right
i'm not one of these i'm going to stamp
the ground until i get my way like
sort of people i'm prepared to meet in
the middle but
as far as those certain things where all
you're doing is being offensive
and you're getting arrested for it for
example you know the chelsea russell
case
she posted rap lyrics on her instagram
that contained
the n-word i'm trying not to get you
demonetised
on my channel on my channel i would just
say it right but i won't get you
right basically she posted rap lyrics on
her instagram
she was arrested context didn't ma she
now has a criminal record and she was
tagged and had to pay a fine
there was also the people that burned
the grenfell tower refugee which i
thought was
pretty spicy even by my standards when i
heard about that i always watched the
video and i was like gee
jesus so that was a bit much even for me
and then they got a whole police
investigation the police were going
through their trash
and everything they find stuff on them
so stuff like that like
they've made a crime to be an [ __ ]
chelsea russell's not an [ __ ]
i want to make that clear like the
grenfell tower guys yeah it's very easy
to make that argument that they were
[ __ ]
but like it's just being a bit of a dick
has become a crime
like if you have like an argument with
someone in public as well you've see i
don't know if you've seen the
uh the police's hate crime operational
guidance handbook
it comes down to perception like say for
example if you were
gay yeah are you no damn
[Laughter]
and we're walking down the street we
accidentally accidentally we're banging
each other yeah and that's on the radio
you can go watch where you're [ __ ]
going and i walk away yeah right
now you as a gay man i didn't say i
slaughtered you i don't know anything
about you
see if you perceive that the reason i
did that or said that to you came from a
place of bigoted hatred
that's enough for an arrest the victim's
perception is what mars
basically the victim gets to decide what
was in that person's head
the victim gets to decide the person's
intent and where do you think we're
going to go with this do you think it's
a slippery slope
the gloves are off now and it's going to
get worse authoritarianism that's the
path that we're going down now i mean
it's okay
we've we've noticed a trend when you
look at places like north korea and
china and all that as well they didn't
happen overnight there was baby steps
you know if you just try
you know a country can't just turn
around and go we're just going to go
fill authoritarian boys like that you'll
be right everybody would kick off
everyone would get angry and it's the
jordan peterson described it the best
way where
the government will encroach you know
two inches and keep going until people
start to get really angry and then it
will stop
then it will wait until everyone comes
down and then it will encroach a little
bit more till they get angry and stop
and they'll just keep doing it and doing
it and doing it and we had it with a
terrorism you know the america get the
patriot act you know we had things like
the snoopers charter also for terrorism
so for terrorism the government
gathering more and more power
and then you had a basically diversity
and stuff like that or why would you be
against this you know the government
controlling what you can
say and the things you can write and the
type of ways you can express yourself oh
but it's in the name of diversity why
would you be against that
racist like that's it's basically it's
not just a case of the government doing
but it's one the government also has a
bunch of brainwashed useful idiots
that are on their side allowing the
government to do this and basically
we're trying to point
out like do you not see the government
are using this as an excuse to grab
more power and that's what they're doing
like when was when was the last time
apart from like really really archaic
like when was the last time
the government got rid of a law that
gave it a hell of a lot more power
like like even surveillance laws and all
that as well you know basically you're
you can be monitored constantly
and we were fine with it because we were
like all but it protects us from
terrorism
yeah well terrorism still happens
doesn't it so it's obviously not working
that way
and like you say i think if he is it
would be a few years ago now but
one of the first uses of this new
terrorist legislation they arrested the
pension at the labor party conference
for shouting at one of the ministers or
something
like terrorism yeah they used
anti-terrorism legislation to arrest
like what
world it's getting pretty mental but
listen one thing i wanted to ask you
because i think a lot of people wouldn't
know this yeah and
you know when we had a long chat that
came up is actually the impact of
like you know you're joking about it you
know there's funny things about it but
also
there was an impact on you in terms of
your employment your work your life
and i think a lot of people wouldn't
know that so maybe tell us a little bit
about that i was accused of
i had jobs i was working in security but
then whenever i tried to get you know
security is a mixing match you just
usually get a text for your phone can
you do a shift
whenever i tried to get stable
employment while doing security on top
of it
basically i would i've always some of
them are trying to be honest in the
interview going
i'm just going to be real with you guys
right now never got a call back so then
i tried to keep it secret just so that i
could get a job and then and all the
places i got into
you know after a week or so or in one
case on my first day
i got recognized people knew who i was
and just that was me straight out the
door gone
and also basically because because
because of the nazi pug thing you know
that basically
what would they say to you they would
turn around and say oh i see i would do
this to the company it would do that to
the company even though
most of the companies that actually did
fire me got a lot more [ __ ]
for firing me than they would have for
late letting me work there because
people managed to find out one of the
security firms that i worked for and now
my boss
at the time he loved it he would get
angry calls
lately people going i can't believe you
hired him you've gotten actually working
for you and he would sit there
like that yeah what are you going to do
no i'm not fighting him in fact i'm
going to offer him extra shifts but
he loved it i miss him but
yeah it was just so it was being
unemployable as a case of
i'm just trying to keep the ball rolling
with my youtube and all that because see
after this is
gone you know what can i do there's no
job there's no place that well high on
me and even you know maybe after that
i'll start arguing in favor of the
welfare states
what's that space um but like so that's
why i'm trying to do what i do but i'm
still getting attacked for what i'm
doing
and i'm sort of like am i am i allowing
to feed myself
you know am i allowed to keep a roof
over my head like what do you want me to
do oh man they keep going after me no
matter what area
i go into it's a case of like okay then
we'll make an agreement i'll i'll drop
everything i'll stop being all free
speech i'll stop being all
right-wing and all that stuff and i'll
just go and get a normal job they won't
they wouldn't even let me have that
no so i'm kind of i'm kind of stuck in
what i'm doing and what what's it i mean
like we joke about it and it is funny
what you know and the ridiculousness and
all the rest of it
but being called a nazi is a pretty
pretty vicious thing to do
it's white noise to me now it doesn't
the world has lost all meaning it's like
the magic effect when you hear the same
thing over and over again it starts to
just lose its meaning and enunciation
and everything like this that's what it
is now
people none of these people know what
actual nazis are like even in that chat
i had with that gentleman yesterday
he didn't even know he thinks like so
just for anyone doesn't know you had a
chat with a
left-leaning comedian that i helped
fully set you up
left left leaning i think it was a
little bit more than leaning but
yeah i think he loves it but
he's flat on the left oh yeah yeah so
left wing he's hanging off the plane
but like he he doesn't know what it was
either basically he thinks that
wanting to deport illegal immigrants
but being completely fine with the legal
ones being here he thinks that's far
right
and i was just no not at all and
obviously he thinks that
not wanting to associate with gay people
as far away if you were calling for the
deaths of or
banning of homosexuality yeah that's far
right yeah that's far right
a lot of muslim countries do that
i'm just saying i thought you didn't
want to get us demonetized
[Laughter]
has shifted so much that even being
a libertarian is considered far right
like that's what i would consider myself
i have a lot of libertarian values
everyone's like
oh you know the government should have
seen sexuality and everything was like
however the government has no [ __ ]
say about who's that the government's
business
yeah that man like was oh we need
government recognition why
it's not your dad's i'm honestly you
don't need you know
validation from the government i don't
give a [ __ ] what the government thinks
about me
you need to recognize my sexuality maybe
you're a little bit needy
ah man government's not stopping
but on the whole being called the nazi
thing it's like amazing to us because
we do this show francis is probably more
left-leaning that i'm kind of somewhere
in the center
immigrant with the jewish heritage yeah
yeah yeah so obviously
no but people are calling us for far
right i've been called alt-right
fascist pro-fascist obviously
that's a good one
they know your own mind so much better
than you crypto fascism
yeah that sounds like a really good
board game
i use crypto authoritarian doesn't back
at them and they get really angry when
you use
the you use their own language back at
them so
so for and all we do on the show is we
try to talk to different people and we
just let them say what say their piece
like we're done with you right yeah
we've tried to challenge you a little
bit we've tried to listen to you we
don't interrupt you we don't try and
pretend that you meant something that
you didn't mean or anything
and that now is far right yeah and it's
like where do you go from here
this is the most see the most progress
that i have seen
comes from talking to people it comes
from talking to people because people
use my associations on me all the time
you spoke to tommy
once absolutely yeah like nearly a year
ago and all that but like
oh you're in ukraine you know nigel
farage blah blah blah and it's like all
your associations
these associations are what i'm basing
my opinions of you on
and i'm just like well i hang out with
communists i talk to anarchists
talk to like full-on liberals social
democrats and everybody i'm like why
why are they getting ignored like i
speak to them too
so why are you not interested in them is
because i speak to everyone
they only get mad about the ones that
you know they like to be mad about these
guys but when you
speak to someone that doesn't suit their
narrative they're not interested
because i've noticed they see that i've
had people who've hated me
outright hated me but assuming i've
approached them and had a chat with them
we talked
regularly now i'm not going to say them
names because they won't outright admit
that they talk to me
because basically they couldn't lose
their jobs and she'll i'll get or
they'll get [ __ ] for the
from their own side because it's sort of
you know don't don't hang out with the
smelly kids
that's literally the mentality that it
is but see how and bringing people sort
of back from the extremes
like see going out and speaking to them
is what does that like you see
how many times have you seen nazis or
white supremacists you know get the
platform get fired from their jobs get
you know punched
and all that has that ever made any of
them change their opinion
no no no it hasn't but speaking to them
does
because one of the fears that i've
identified in the far right
is they think even if they abandon their
beliefs
society will still shun them they're
like i can't come back like a society
just like what you're talking about with
you yeah yeah
society sees nazism as that [ __ ] don't
wash off
like that that's forever right but even
though i thought we used to like the
nice stories of a guy that was like i
was in the kkk for years and now i'm not
and you know i'm
i'm here with my black wife and my
wife's son
that's different
yeah redemption is good you know when
you hear i used to be an outright racist
i'm not anymore no i'm a good productive
member of society good
those are lovely stories that's
excellent but not anymore and
it's like the far right know this well
some of them go i want to leave
but i'm not going to be accepted back
nobody wants me back and
all they can do is hang around with the
far writers you know getting further and
further you know but just becoming
ideologues because they're not hearing
conflicting opinions
whereas if you hold out you know the
friendly hand invite them out for a
drink be nice to them and basically make
it clear to them you know if you abandon
your beliefs
and come back to the late you know we
will be here for you
and everything in that works that works
if you reach out to them and be nice and
that you'll get people go
oh he's asking you to be nice to nazis i
was like well it works
like come up with a better one because
you just beating them up in the streets
not [ __ ] working
my man so if anything my idea is more
effective so why are you booing me i'm
right
you've got a lot of criticism for being
a ukip supporter haven't you yeah
can you uh can you just explain a little
bit why why you support ukip
it's it's just because the no other
party cares about freedom of speech
none of them do and everyone seems to
think that you know i'm fully 100
ideologically aligned do you know how
funny is
bringing up the concept of legalizing
weed that you kept means
i love doing it i love doing it i don't
mind because i
think we should legalize weed but when
you mention it in the the room they're
like oh
man they get all upset and i'm like no
we should do it
but also i'm also still a scottish
nationalist
really upsets them but um but it's like
they're the only part that care about
freedom of speech
none of the other ones do label don't
care tories don't care lib dems
you know so that's the problem see if
and then
you get people to go why don't you
associate with like why don't you speak
at any left-wing free speech events
where are they where are they you know
find me a left-wing free speech event
i'll
happily go and speak at it besides
because most of the people on the
left-wing aren't having the free speech
attacked i've seen people on the left
wing
getting the free speech attacked because
they are not left enough
yeah like most of it is coming from the
authoritarian left who are
really really shockingly everyone's like
oh the rise in the far right it's the
authoritarian left that you want to
watch
they're the ones that have grown in
massive numbers and it's universities
that are doing it
well we know a little bit about that
uh listen i our time's almost up uh we
would love to chat to you for longer but
you're busy man
you're performing here tonight and we
got to let you go so final question
francis go for it
uh the one we always do what are the
thing what's some of the things that
we're not talking about as a society but
we
really need to be extermination of
furries
okay you're not just talking about
people with beards right no no no no no
no
we can kill them that's fine
as far as i thought he's a protected
class do you know what
he is i don't know this is brilliant you
don't know what a furry is no
oh my boy um
as a person yeah who adopts an
anthropomorphized animal persona
sometimes they just like to role play
sometimes there is a bit of a sexual
element they'll even take it to the full
extent of buying
a full fursuit so they self-identify as
a rabbit
pretty much okay but these far suits go
for thousands by the way i found out and
they'll have events they'll role play
and they'll have a lot of
fun and i think if they want to be
animals then it should be legal for us
to hunt them
[Laughter]
well
that's fine they were going to get shot
anyways
thank you so much for coming in uh
follow marcus on twitter watch his
youtube channel
uh and as always subscribe to us on
youtube at trigger pod on all the social
media and we will see you very soon with
another episode
uh absolutely see oh by the way like
share do all the rest of it do you
reckon you can train
a rabbit to be a nazi maybe well we've
got an expert here yeah yeah
we get a whole legion of them give me a
week
and on that note guys thanks a lot see
you next week bye
you